we've got actor Jesse Tyler Ferguson we
don't want to cut any of his time he's
taking a Victory lap returning to his
Tony award-winning role in take me out
it's back on Broadway for a limited run
you probably know Ferguson yeah you know
him from his critically acclaimed role
as Mitchell Pritchett on the hitcom the
hit sitcom we remember this Modern
Family I love this show he received five
Emmy nominations for that but he rose to
prominence and musicals like on the town
and the 25th Annual Putnam County
Spelling Bee I saw that too Jesse I
forgot about that you I saw you in that
Ferguson returned to the stage this year
and the Revival of take me out that's
good too the play is about a star
baseball player coming out as gay he
plays the manager Mason talking in this
preview about his love of baseball
then with two outs in the bottom of the
ninth the miracle happened
we got a hit
then another
and then another and another and another
and think Mets versus Braves June 30th
2000 when the Mets went into the eighth
losing 8-1 and scored 10 runs in a
single inning to take the game 11-8 and
we took this game
and that boys and girls is why he won a
Tony Award thank you very much Jesse
Tyler Ferguson is in the Stu hi Jesse
Tyler Ferguson welcome oh we're so glad
you're here because we know it's a pain
in the butt to get up early we're very
glad you're here so it was a limited run
originally it was supposed to end and
what happened well we close and the next
night we won a Tony Award for best
survival I won a Tony Award um we had
two other actors nominated in the cast
as well so it ended on a real high and
um Barry weissler who's a great producer
producer Chicago and waitress said I
think this show deserves another run so
he uh he gathered us back together and
we're gonna run again until February 5th
so it's been a four month break did the
Lions come back to you they did they did
they really did yeah I've been living
with this play for so long because we
started rehearsing it before the
pandemic so I've I've known that I was
gonna do this play for almost four years
now so I've been living with this
character for a very long time well
since you've been living with the
character this is why it's hard for me
to understand when you said that you
suffer from imposter syndrome do you
know what you do and who you are are we
surprised hear that from you yeah I
think I think a lot of a lot of actors
do that I know I do hear that and I
think I you know Dennis O'Hare who
played the role originally won a Tony
Award for it as well and I saw that
performance it really stuck with me so I
was stepping into shoes that were very
familiar to me and that they felt like I
was uh you know it was like such a
allotted performance and it was it was
very intimidating to offer up a
different interpretation so you did do
you even play baseball do you like the
game of baseball I I I like the game yes
I've never played I've never played I
was not I was an indoor kid yeah I mean
you wanted to be on Broadway since the
time you were in high school and this
has been yeah a picture of you I think
uh from high school this is gonna be
terrible we got it we got it oh a little
good thing
yeah I'm where I'm holding a fan of the
Opera mask that's high school that's
high school I really loved phantomy
Opera what would you think what would
you tell that High School Jesse Tyler
first oh my gosh I would say maybe
rethink holding the Phantom of the Opera
mask um but I you know I I think I would
just have to push on and persevere and
also get used to having a thick skin
because this business is very tough yeah
all right first let me say um your
mustache is glorious thank you well with
the turtleneck yeah Tony and I saw you
were like turtleneck mustache killing it
um but you know this play originally
debuted in 2003 yeah um but how is this
story maybe even your character relevant
today
well you know I think homophobia still
exists obviously we have a toxic
masculinity still exists we
Richard Greenberg when you wrote this
play thought I need to have this play
produced quickly because it's only a
matter of time before a huge Superstar
baseball player athlete athlete in
general comes out of the closet yeah
it's only a matter of time and here we
are yeah yeah here we are that's right
but you know most people still think of
you as Modern Family I saw an interview
with Sarah Hyland recently and she was
talking about you Jesse performing her
wedding ceremonies because she said uh
fake TV uncle but real life friend and
that it meant the world that you
actually got your credentials to do this
for her I did that's so sweet I did it
was the last minute I was the last
minute replacement for Ty Burrell who
had a family emergency and so she gave
me about 10 days notice and so I called
Tyber raw I was like what do you got so
far because I gotta fast track this
thing
um but yeah I I you know it's very easy
to become ordained it's you just
basically fill out a piece of paper and
then they send you a certificate no but
she said you were really good I did I
did put a lot I mean and she means the
world to me so I really wanted to be a
special you mean the world to her I know
now you've got the cocaine bear I can't
wait to see you in there
I know I'm really proud of it I think
this movie is going to do great I hope
so I I mean I'm in it I don't make it to
the entire film I'll just say that much
yes we've heard well it looks like a lot
of people don't make it yeah it's kind
of true but Elizabeth Banks our director
just did such a great job with the tone
of this wacky film and um oh my gosh
look at me yeah up in that tree yeah um
it was a lot of fun you know I got to
see like the Robert Redford hair and
like you know it's set in 1985 which is
a fun era to play and you now have a
second baby Beckett and Sullivan so
they're in LA and you're here yes how we
rarely ask men this question but how are
you balancing that because they're over
there and you're over here I mean it's
very hard there's a lot of face timing
um I'm trying to get back as often as I
can I was home for you know 22 hours
over Thanksgiving
um oh man it's It's Tricky it's really
tricky yeah it's hard for us to balance
that too all right
Jesse Tyler Ferguson thank you so much
we're big fans of you